it's now an elaborate treehouse in the
wildlife reach aberdare's forest in
central Kenya back in 1952 when Queen
Elizabeth first visited as a princess
this is how it looked
the only thing that has been constant is
a water hole that attracts wild animals
every evening and what brings in
thousands of tourists every year the
story of Treetops Lodge has been told
Andrew told
princess Elizabeth was here when her
father died and she became Queen Mary
shows me exactly where the original
Treehouse stood before it banned down
bugua was a Potter and was selected to
help carry the princess luggage to the
room it was a time of colonial
oppression some white people did not
treat Kenyans very well they would beat
us they took our hand here to the
founders here they had thousands of
livestock but it would only allow us to
own at most 15 Goods only Goods the then
princess visited Kenya at a very tense
period the beginning of an uprising and
within a year young Kenyan Freedom
Fighters declared war on her government
they killed dozens of British settlers
and their sympathizers to the beginning
of the end of colonialism
Kenya gained independence in 1963. it
was one of many African countries to do
so that decades it appears as if many of
policy makers in Britain and the West
have not accepted the fact
that Africans are independent
they although there was that
Independence they tend to think of
Africans as Perpetual words
children to be guided age remains at the
heart of Brazil's engagement with Africa
the UK is finding it difficult to
compete with China in trade and building
infrastructure support for Africa it is
not that Africans what don't want the
West they want the West
but they also want a little respect and
the right to decide
uh who to deal with if the Chinese deals
are not good
get rid of them in the bridge deals are
not good get rid of them while it's
during the Queen's Reign that Syria's
human rights abusers were committed in
Kenya she is remembered fondly she
visited the country several times a
museum dedicated to her is filled with
souvenirs from her visits
Britain's connection with Africa is
evolving as is The post-colonial
Stereotype that the relationship is all
about handouts
Africa continues to receive its aid but
some analysts say the UK is now more
interested in promoting trade Catherine
zoy Al Jazeera Central Kenya